look at people like cardi B putting put
on the pedestal that she's on that's
terrifying you have a stripper who
notoriously was drugging men and robbing
them and doing all these different
things and guess who decides to
interview her Joe Biden Joe Biden wants
to give her a platform because that's
how he feels that he can reach the Black
and Hispanic communities and that's very
telling on how the left views people of
color that he went and got someone that
was borderline illiterate to be the
person to convey his different talking
points I do think it's fair to point out
though
I I think everybody elevates the lowest
common denominator because it sells but
that being said I mean if you compare
cardi B and Joe Biden Joe Biden is
corrupt and crooked and represents like
the worst of American political
political class as is Hillary Clinton
and then here he is sitting with cardi B
I mean I think and there's I like Carter
you'd be more than Joe Biden I mean
hasn't she come out and said some stuff
that's actually fairly based she did
call out the Dalai Lama for the weird
stuff about yeah she did she did she did
say that that was weird